sur public sénat bonjour à tous et
bienvenue sur public sénat à suivre ce
matin sur notre antenne l'audition de
christian noyer le gouverneur de la
banque de france par la commission des
finances du sénat
cette audition intervient alors qu'une
réunion des ministres des finances et
des banquiers centraux du g20 se tiendra
à paris les 18 et 19 février elle sera
consacrée à la réforme du système
monétaire international
un système qu'il faut aménager selon
christian noyer
pour lui le système actuel a permis de
traverser la crise mais il faut
l'adapter aux problèmes du futur
je vous rappelle que la france préside
le g20 depuis novembre 2010 et qu'elle
assume cette responsabilité jusqu'au
sommet de novembre 2011 et qu'une de ses
priorités
et d'ailleurs à la réforme du système
monétaire international très bonne
matinée à tous je le gouverneur merci
d'avoir répondu à l'invitation de la
commission des finances
nous sommes toujours très heureux de
vous accueillir vous êtes un familier de
la commission puisque votre dernière
audition romontois juin 2010 dans le
cadre de l'examen du projet de loi de
régulation bancaire et financière
mais depuis 2003 je note que vous êtes
venus chaque année devant la commission
et que depuis depuis la crise financière
votre présence a été de deux ou trois
fois par an merci d'avoir répondu à
nouveau à nos souhaits de vous entendre
depuis six mois à l'actualité a continué
d'être chargé pour les banques au plan
conjoncturel
l'extension de la crise de la dette
européenne à l'irlande et au portugal a
ravivé certaines inquiétudes en
particulier sur l'état réel du secteur
bancaire irlandais
qui a été presque entièrement
nationalisée de même les stress tests
réalisés sur 91 banques européennes
en juillet dernier n'ont pas totalement
convaincu du fait de certaines lacunes
en matière notamment de liquidités et
d'expositions aux dette souveraines et à
l'économie des états dits périphériques
s'agissant des réformes structurelles le
comité de bâle a rendu sa copie en
septembre dernier et confirmé certaines
orientations sur une appréciation plus
rigoureuse des titres constitutive du
capital le relèvement important mais
progressif des exigences en capital de
tijuana où l'introduction d'un ratio de
levier
certaines précisions doivent encore être
apportées sur les deux ratios de
liquidité sans doute les dispositions
les plus contestées
le traitement des titres hybrides et le
coussin de capital des établissements
systémiques
enfin au plan national le niveau de
centralisation à la caisse des dépôts
des encours d'épargné réglementée a
suscité vous l'avez constaté de vifs
débats
le président de la république a
également insisté sur une meilleure
utilisation des encours décentralisée au
profit des pme
reprenant en cela une disposition que
nous avions inséré dans la loi de
régulation bancaire et financière
contre l'avis du gouvernement nous
souhaitons donc dans un premier temps
vous entendre réagir pendant si vous le
voulez bien une dizaine de minutes sur
les thèmes suivants avant d'aborder
d'autres questions la crise de la dette
souveraine
le débat sur le fonds européen de
stabilité financière et la politique
d'achat de titres souverains par la
banque centrale européenne et
l'eurosystème vous entendre sur le débat
relatif au niveau de centralisation des
encours du livret a et du livret de
développement durable
bhl à la caisse des dépôts et
consignations et sur l'utilisation des
encours décentralisée au profit des pme
vous entendre aussi sur les grands axes
de bâle iii est le nouveau défi pour les
banques françaises
consistant à mieux capter à mieux
valoriser dans leur bilan les dépôts et
l'épargnent de la clientèle de détail
merci de nous éclairer sur ces trois
points
pendant une bonne dizaine de minutes et
puis ensuite vous serez invité à
répondre aux questions que nous
souhaiterons vous posez monsieur le
gouverneur merci infiniment monsieur le
président merci encore une fois de votre
invitation d'habitation de la commission
des finances vous savez comme je suis
toujours heureux d'avoir l'occasion de
m'exprimer devant la représentation
nationale tout spécialement je dois dire
devant votre votre commission
la finesse des questions que vous me
posez ne rend pas forcément ma tâche
plus facile mais mes m'aide beaucoup à
voir quels sont les problèmes les plus
importants pour pour la france
à chaque moment est donc dans mon métier
c'est c'est une aide considérable
en tout cas je le juge ainsi monsieur le
président je vais donc reprend les les
questions que vous avez bien voulu me
poser en commençant par la crise de la
dette souveraine
je dirais quand on essaie de prendre un
tout petit peu de recul me semble avoir
quatre causes essentielles qui se
conforte le node d'ailleurs la première
c'est que la politique budgétaire des
états a été insuffisamment rigoureuse
les états n'ont pas voulu interpréter
correctement le pacte de stabilité et de
croissance était dire vous pour
reprendre une expression que je crois
vous est cher monsieur le président tout
casser de voudenay entendu le règlement
de copropriété de la zone euro soit que
ça décrit très bien l'état des choses ce
règlement de copropriété voulait que le
déficit public ne s'est pas en moyenne
un chiffre proche de l'équilibré
c était en gros on doit être l équilibre
sur le cycle il ya des moments où on est
en excédent des moments où on est en
déficit
aussi la moyenne est légèrement en
dessous -0 3 - 0 5 ce n'est pas très
grave mais on ne doit pas s'en écarter
horse a été systématiquement interprété
comme la règle c'est -3% et temps en
temps dans les situations de
l'économique n'est pas très bonne mais
on va au delà c'est pas bien mais c'est
pas grave
donc cette mauvaise interprétation cette
nouvelle application est la première
cause la seconde c'est que nous n'avons
pas ça c'est peut-être
un petit défaut de conception à
l'origine nous n'avons pas mise en en
place un cadre similaire pour la
surveillance de la compétitivité des
états quand on a quand on appartient une
monnaie unique et que on ne se préoccupe
pas de savoir si l'évolution des coûts
pas seulement les salaires mais
l'ensemble des coûts de production va
plus vite que la cible de 2 d'inflation
de stabilité des prix qui est celle de
la banque centrale européenne on
s'expose à perdre de la pompe corrigé
bien sûr des gains de productivité qu'on
peut faire dans chaque économie on
s'expose tout naturellement à des pertes
de compétitivité qui s'accumulent année
après année et au bout de dix ans si la
divergence était très forte entre les
états dans certaines régions certains
pays de la zone
on n'est plus du tout compétitifs ça ça
a été quelque chose qui était négligé la
les les membres du conseil des
gouverneurs de la bce on répétait cette
alerte ou sept
cette inquiétude au gouvernement assez
fréquemment
mais ça a été relativement peu écoutés
la troisième raison qui avec les autres
c'est que la gouvernance n'a pas été n'a
pas été bonne à dire que le il est clair
que la surveillance effectuée par les
pairs et même par la commission a été
insuffisamment rigoureuse trop permissif
d'ailleurs les états eux mêmes avaient
cherché à affaiblir le pacte de
stabilité et croissance une pacte de
tricheurs et donc on voit bien que il ya
eu un effort volontaire pour affaiblir
une discipline qui est qui était déjà
probablement
enfin qui était qui était indispensable
mais qui aurait pu être plus rigoureuse
et quatrièmement géré il ya eu du côté
de la surveillance bancaire des
faiblesses dans certaines parties de
l'europe
d'ailleurs dans l'ensemble du monde et
c'est ce à quoi nous essayons de de
répondre aujourd'hui
alors le dispositif qu'il a été pris on
va les orientations étaient plus pour
l'instant me paraissent bonnes consiste
premièrement à renforcer très
sérieusement le cadre de surveillance
budgétaire et les règles de du pacte de
stabilité et de croissance enfants les
faire les rendre vraiment effective
deuxièmement mettre en place une
surveillance de la compétitivité
comparée des pays pour faire corriger ce
qui doit l'être
et troisièmement mettre en place comme
ça a déjà été fait avec le fsf un
soutien financier pour les états qui
sont dans une situation telle que ils
ont besoins en accompagnement d'un plan
de redressement d'un soutien financier
parce que les marchés spontanément ne
leur font pas confiance donc ils n'ont
pas rétabli une situation plus solide de
leur compétitivité et de leurs finances
publiques
c'est au fond la philosophie des
interventions du fonds monétaire
international qui est appliqué à
l'europe
comme vous le savez les interventions se
font de façon conjointe sur la base de
deux plans de redressement qui sont
communs ou fmi et à l'union et à
l'europe et donc il me semble que c'est
le bon dispositif alors le débat à
l'heure actuelle se focalise pour le
mécanisme futures sur deux idées
la première c'est est ce qu'il ne
devrait mais ce qu'on ne devrait pas
chercher à avoir un montant
effectivement disponibles qu'ils soient
de l'ordre de grandeur de ce qui avait
été annoncé qu'il avait été annoncée
pour ce dispositif 440 milliards d'euros
auxquels s'ajoutaient 60
il ya un dispositif antérieur géré par
la commission
en réalité ces 440 milliards d'euros ne
sont pas vraiment disponibles parce que
pour obtenir la meilleure notation
le triple à il a fallu monter des
dispositifs qui gèle une partie des
montants qu'on peut emprunter et donc
puisque c'était l'intention et ma vie à
juste titre des gouvernements de la zone
euro d'avoir une force de frappe qui
représente 440 milliards d'euros qui
elle-même combiné avec ce que le fmi
peut faire aboutissaient à des montants
tout à fait dissuasif pour la
spéculation me semble que si on pouvait
augmenter la capacité effective de prêt
dans ces temps de grandeur ce serait
bien deuxièmement faut-il flexibiliser
les mesures d'intervention j'ai déjà dit
que à titre personnel j étais j'ai été
favorables représentent abc a d'ailleurs
indiqué la même chose il me semble que
dès lors qu'on veut mettre en place un
mécanisme définitif avoir le plus de
flexibilité possible par exemple de
passer interdire s'il y avait un intérêt
cela d'effectuer des achats sur le
marché secondaire pour faciliter le
retour sur le marché de de certains
gènes des états le fait le cas échéant
de prévoir des lignes de brides de 2,2
crédit de précaution comme le fmi en a
mis en place ces dernières années sont
des options qui me paraissent qui me
paraît très intéressante
voilà
enfin concernant le programme d'achat
titre de bce et de l'eurosystème
nous avons effectivement alors après une
série de mesures que vous connaissez sur
les taux d'intérêt la location intégrale
à taux fixe pour facilité de
refinancement du système bancaire dans
la période de très grande tension que
nous avons connu dans laquelle nous
sommes encore aujourd'hui
d'élargissement du du pool de collatéral
de garanties que nous admettons pour
faciliter également ce financement de
l'aide au redémarrage du marché des
obligations sécurisées à long terme des
banques pour faciliter le financement à
l'investissement de par le système
bancaire économie de la zone euro une
opération d'achat lit de cover band qui
a très bien fonctionné puisque le marché
est reparti et fonctionne d'une façon
tout à fait satisfaisante aujourd'hui
des volumes d'émissions assez important
le dernier sujet auquel nous avons été
confrontés c'est le dysfonctionnement de
la transmission de la politique
monétaire je m'explique
lorsque l'abbé civ décide fixé son taux
d'intérêt à 1% et que parce qu'il ya une
crise de la dette souveraine dans un
pays les banques en réalité subissent
très largement la décote qui est imposé
à l'état donc les banques au lieu
d'emprunter à autour de 20% sur les
marchés à court terme se voient obligés
d'emprunter à court terme à 8 10 12 % ne
pas dire 20 à ce moment là ça veut dire
que le taux des crédits évidemment suit
le coude refinancement des banques donc
la bce se trouve avoir fixé son taux
d'intérêt à 1% et dans certaines régions
de sa zone le taux effectivement
pratiqué abouti à des chiffres
dd nombre à deux chiffres ça veut dire
qu'il ya plus de transmission de la
politique monétaire
nous avons été confrontés à cette
situation et donc pour pour essayer de
contrer cela nous avons mis en place un
programme d'achat titre évidemment ça
n'était concevable que comme une aide à
la restauration d'une transmission plus
normal ça n'était concevable donc que si
l'état lui même prenait les mesures
nécessaires drastiques pour restaurer sa
situation budgétaire sa crédibilité
et si l'ensemble des états de la zone
euro mettez en place un dispositif qui
assurait le refinancement de l'état
autrement nous aurions financer les
états sans limite et donc et donc nous
avions absolument besoin des décisions
fortes qui ont été prises par les états
et qui est ce
c'est c'est donc une période extrêmement
critique
le programme lui même deux pour les
états qui qui est qu'ils ont pris les
mesures nécessaires et qui pour deux
d'entre eux ont reçu le soutien
approprié
le programme s'est relativement bien
passé nous avons c'est vrai aujourd'hui
encore des taux d'intérêt assez élevé
dans ces pays mais nous avons réussi à
contrer l'excessive volatilité de ces
taux et les embardées qui rendait
complètement inopérante notre politique
monétaire pour bien montrer que ce
n'était pas un programme de 2 d'achats
massifs et de création de liquidités
nous avons tenu à stériliser
systématiquement les montants que nous
achetions ce que nous avons repris la
liquidité qui va lancer dans des
opérations spécifiques dans le marché
naturellement la solution des problèmes
viendra que de la restauration de la
confiance des marchés de du succès des
programmes qui ont été mis en place sur
la seconde question monsieur le
président le le niveau de centralisation
des livrets a et de livrets de
développement durable
pardon je dirai les choses de façon
suivante la situation actuelle et la
situation prévisible n'est pas alarmante
et apparaître plutôt confortable à la
condition de ne pas déstabiliser la
collecte c'est qu'aujourd'hui le taux de
2 125% été fixée par l'initiateur est
largement respectée parce qu'on était à
la fin d'année dernière à 156 % la
croissance des encours de livrets à
étaient de 5 ennemis pour cent l'an
dernier tout ou livret confondues
étaient trois et demi pour cent l'an
dernier
les banques ont commencé à faire
quelques prêts au logement social
pour l'instant ce sont des montants
faibles mais moins de 10 milliards
d'encours mais c'est l'ébauché d'une
politique qui peut être effectivement
intéressante pour la réalisation des
objectifs fixés par le par le parlement
la hausse récente du taux à 2% du taux à
2% va évidemment
conforter le la collecte de ce produit
je dirais que nous sommes passés par un
creux dans les taux d'intérêt peu de
chances que nous revenions 20 des taux
si bas que nous avons connue en tout cas
ce serait pas un bon signe fera signe
que la crise reviendrai et comme on sait
que les épargnants un comportement
partie nominaliste de s'attendent à ce
que la collecte sur ce type de produits
soit moustiques d'une façon structurelle
le produit conçu de telle sorte que
c'est un produit attractif puisqu'il a
une rémunération qui est
systématiquement supérieures à
l'inflation sont pleinement et fiscaux
ni sociaux pour une épargne liquide à
tout moment et garanties par l'état et
donc nous nous considérons que
l'hypothèse basse et prudent très
prudent de collecte quand on fait des
prévisions plusieurs années c'est un
chiffre de l'ordre de 2 et demi pour
cent ce qui veut dire que le risque de
franchissement du seuil de 125 % nous
paraît extrêmement faible encore une
fois si on ne déstabilise pas la
collecte
je trouve personnellement que le
dispositif qui proposait aujourd'hui
avec un seuil d alerte à 135% est un bon
dispositif je peux difficilement dire le
contraire parce que je crois avoir été
un de ceux qui l'ont suggéré mais
je crois que que fragments nous avons un
dispositif qui leur permettent de
collecter tout ce qu'il faut encore
faut-il encore faut-il ne pas prendre
des mesure contre-productive et
décourager la collecte c'est le seul
risque que je vois de décourager la
collecte il ya trois points à considérer
le premier c'est précisément le niveau
de centralisation pour ce niveau de
centralisation prenait pas considérer
pardon c'est que les nouveaux réseaux
sont à l'origine de la hausse des dépôts
non pas les anciens réseaux sont les
nouveaux réseaux c'est épingle vient
très largement du transfert d'autres
comptes
c'est à dire que les établissements
nouveaux ont assisté ou ou facilité ou
provoqué le transfert d'autres comptes
de dépôt et des pins vers les livrets
réglementés et dans les années
prochaines on sait qu'ils vont devoir
transférer quel que soit le taux de
centralisation des montants supérieurs
où il faudrait imaginer une collecte
faramineuse mais qu'on voit un collègue
l'a transféré des montants supérieurs au
montant que additionnel qu'ils vont
collecter soit en gros on part d'une
situation où les anciens réseaux
collecte 87% ce coin de centralise 87 %
de la collecte et les nouveaux réseaux
35% et donc et donc on voit bien que ils
vont transférer plus que ce qu'ils vont
collecter et donc plus on leur demande
de transférer des montants importants et
vite vers la caisse des dépôts
plus ils vont être découragés de vendre
le produit à la limite une façon simple
de ne pas transférer ces deux
parle pas de tuer le produit mais
d'encourager leurs clients un noeud à ne
pas déposer là dessus aller vers
d'autres produits d'épargné à ce moment
là ils n'auront pas besoin d'assister à
ce transfert
donc si on va trop loin je dirais le
mieux est l'ennemi du bien
c'est un peu comme le théorème de la
faire en matière fiscale c'est très
satisfaisant de se dire on veut imposer
à 100% certain certains revenus si on
impose à 100% certain revenu on est
absolument sûr du résultat il n'y aura
pas de revenus qui sont imposés 100 %
des revenus vont disparaître parce que
les gens vont faire en sorte de ne pas
les gagner c'est la même chose en
matière de centralisation au delà d'un
certain taux de centralisation vous
décourager la collecte et les banques
s'arrangeront pour envoyer leurs
déposants sur d'autres produits
donc il faut faire extrêmement attention
à ça ce phénomène est d'ailleurs
renforcée
accessoirement par les ratios de
liquidité donc généralement dans un
instant qu'ils prennent en compte
beaucoup mieux les dépôts que d'autres
produits que leur intérêt pour avant des
dépôts classique plutôt que des dépôts
qui sont en partie sentant lésé va
encore augmenter
le dernier point qu'il faut avoir à
l'esprit c'est que le taux de
commissionnement qui est prévu n'est pas
très incitatif
le taux de commissionnement qui a été
abaissée qui a baissé dans le projet
déjà à 0 5% n'est pas très incitatif
parce qu'il est plutôt plus faible que
ce qu'on gagne sur d'autres produits
et comme en plus il est prévu d'avoir
des taux qui varie entre 0,16 et un peu
plus de 0,5 pour certaines banques le
taux va être considéré comme très des
incitatifs
donc si vous ajoutez un taux de
commission très des incitatifs et un
taux de centralisation très des
incitatifs
là on crée vraiment un risque pour le
financement du logement social et donc
voilà on je vous livre cela je trouve
que encore une fois le mieux est
l'ennemi du bien à mon avis le
équilibre qui était trouvée si on
considère que le taux de rémunération
est de 0,5 et le taux de centralisation
normale vers lequel on converge surtout
en convergeant onze ans plus tôt quand
cet enjeu moi jouer beaucoup de sept
changements parce que ça allège
considérablement la rapidité du flux ils
ont ça laisse plus de temps pour
collecter davantage et donc le surcroît
de centralisation par rapport à la
collecte est réduit année après année
je pense que cet équilibre est
convenable mais si on allait plus loin à
mon avis on comprendrait des risques sur
la question enfin des grands à oui
pardon l'utilisation des encours alors
sur l'utilisation d un cours
la situation se présente de la façon
suivante
nous collectons trimestriellement à
banque de france avec des états
spécifique des informations détaillées
sur sur ces emplois
il ya deux règles et ces deux règles
sont sans aucun compte
sans aucune hésitation possible très
largement respectés
l'encours doit représenter au minimum 80
% de l'encours décentralisée de
l'épargné réglementée disons 100 % de 20
82 90 ça dépend combien sont mis sur les
ailes et les emplois à des fins
écologiques mais le ratio aujourd'hui et
de 262% puisqu'on à 244 milliards de
prêts aux pme pour 93 milliards si je
prends 80% un peu plus de 100 milliards
si je prends 100% et donc il n'y a aucun
problème et toutes les banques
françaises respectent ce ratio le
deuxième la deuxième règle c'est les
flux nouveaux crédits aux pme
c'est celle que vous évoquiez monsieur
le président qui a été introduite
dans la loi de régulation bancaire et
financière ces flux nouveaux doivent
égalé au moins trois quarts de
l'accroissement de la collecte en fait
les flux nouveaux ont représenté l'an
dernier plus de 10 fois la collecte est
même si on se reporte est uniquement au
seul crédit à l'investissement dès pme
le ratio serait très largement respectés
donc je n'ai pas je n'ai aucune
inquiétude sur le fait que ce soit
respectée tant des les chiffres sont
plus un pinson sont beaucoup plus
importants en termes de de financement
des pme que de que deux collègues qui
doit être affecté nous avons alors je
dois le dire une difficulté qui est une
difficulté de type qui tient qui tient à
la définition des pm fixées par l'arrêté
d'application c'est pas la loi qui est
une définition
pardonnez moi un tout petit peu
bureaucratique complexe unique mal
adapté je crois pas que cette ceci était
voulue par le par le législateur oui
c'est un arrêté un arrêté qui prévoit
des règles pour définir les pme qui sont
des règles à la fois alternative est
cumulative on peut avoir moins soit
moins de 250 salariés soit un chiffre
d'affaires inférieur à 50 millions
d'euros ou un total de bilan inférieur à
43 millions d'euros
tout ça est extrêmement compliqué et
d'ailleurs discriminant entre les
secteurs puisque les totaux de bilans
varient énormément une taille en réalité
voisine dedans entreprises suivant le
secteur d'activité dans lequel on opère
ces indications ne figure pas dans les
bases de données des banques pur et
simple raison qu'elles sont différentes
des règles françaises européennes et
internationales qu'on applique dans tous
les autres domaines qui sont simplement
que la pme c'est moins de 50 millions
d'euros de chiffre d'affaires c'est ça
qui existe partout
donc c'est ça qui est dans les systèmes
informatiques des banques et donc
je vais proposer au ministère de
l'économie des finances et de
l'industrie d'aligner la définition des
pme sur la réglementation française
européenne et pour lahm sera réglé voilà
même si encore une fois je n'ai aucune
inquiétude sur le fait que d'ores et
déjà les ratios sont respectés mais je
veux dire c'est quand même extrêmement
ennuyeuse pas pouvoir démontrer que dans
la définition retenue par la
réglementation on a des chiffres très
précis
voilà s'agisse d'un don en s'opposant
s'agissant enfin de la publication par
la banque de france des encours et
d'effets le nouveau des crédits aux pme
et aux entreprises créées depuis moins
de trois ans je vous savez j'avais dit
au gouvernement j'ai même écrit au
gouvernement je crois l'avoir dit au
sein de cette commission que comme ça ne
correspondait pas à des définitions que
nous avions 7 6 et est très compliqué
même bio gouvernement c'est impossible
ceci étant nous avons fait un travail de
statistiques tout à fait considérable
l'année dernière et au début de cette
année pour essayer alors ce sera pas une
ne livrera pas des chiffres comptables
mais des chiffres statistiquement nous
souhaitons qu'ils aient une très grande
robustesse statistics pour ça que les
travaux sont complexes et j'espère que
nous pourrons publier partir de la fin
du premier semestre
une estimation
de ces de ces flux et de ses encours tel
que souhaité par le parlement en tout
cas c'est l'objectif que nous nous
sommes fixés et en général quand nous
fixons des objectifs nouveaux nous les
tenons enfin sur sur bâle iii je dirais
en quelques monde sur le président parce
que je contretemps le dispositif
prudentiel tel que vous l'avez
admirablement décrit en quelques mots me
paraît être un bon système renforcer la
qualité du capital renforcé la quantité
du capital il fallait trouver le juste
équilibre pour améliorer
considérablement la solidité du système
bancaire par tous surtout avoir des
définitions homogène pour être sûr que
d'un état à l'autre on n'avait pas des
degrés de résistance très différents
avec apparemment les mêmes ratios le
travail qui a été fait est très bon en
même temps il fallait éviter de
pénaliser le financement de l'économie
donc le la solution a consisté d'abord à
trouver je crois un bon équilibre
montant de ratio qui est exigeant mais
raisonnable et deuxièmement est allé la
mise en oeuvre d'une qualitatives et
quantitatives sur sur une grande partie
de la décennie puisqu'on termine le 1er
janvier 2018 dans cette réforme dans
cette volée prudentielles un des
éléments qui me paraît le plus important
c'est le fait que nous avait nous avons
considérablement augmenter les exigences
liées aux activités de marché les
exigences liées aux activités de marché
ont été indépendamment de la définition
du capital multiplié par 4 3 4 en
moyenne
et puis les autres volets sont le ratio
de levier qui est également un ratio
sous observation pour une raison simple
c'est que
nous souhaitons que ce soit un ratio qui
soit simplement complémentaires qui soit
une façon de vérifier qu'aucune banque
ne se crée un levier d'endettement
excessif mais normalement c'est le ratio
sur actifs pondérés qui doit rester le
principal et donc nous voulons tester ce
que cela donne en pratique donc une
période d'observation et nsr d'autre
part nous avions des problèmes de
divergence comptable entre les normes
internationales et les normes
américaines qui ont dans leurs cadres à
ce levier un impact énorme puisque
notamment les modalités de compensation
des opérations dérivés étaient
complètement différentes et très peu de
compensation système ios mais un système
international utilisé par l'europe
beaucoup de compensation dans le système
américain les deux normalisateurs
comptables viennent ces jours derniers
de faire une proposition commune qui moi
me semble excellente
j'espère que nous pourrons avoir un
accord là dessus de la même façon qu'ils
viennent de se mettre d'accord sur une
proposition en matière de de
provisionnements sur le cycle
provisionnement prévisionnel ci serait
là aussi une excellente nouvelle puisque
c'est un une des difficultés que qui est
bien apparu avec la crise l'absence de
provisionnement prospectif fait que l'on
attendait que la catastrophe arrive pour
provisionner
enfin comme vous l'avez dit monsieur le
président on a deux ratios de liquidité
qui sont sous observation en période
d'observation
ces ratios ont correspondent à un vrai
besoin sur le fond la crise était autant
une crise de liquidité qu'une crise de
solvabilité et le degré de
transformation dans le système bancaire
mondial était excessif pour autant ces
deux ratios parce que nous sommes
beaucoup concentrés sur la solvabilité
ces deux rations été faite très vite il
présente à mon avis quelques défauts
par exemple dans la définition des
actifs liquides
malgré un certain rééquilibrage que nous
avons faits au mois d'octobre
il existe encore une une prééminence
extrêmement forte pour les titres
publics en effet que avec la crise de la
dette souveraine les titres publics
n'étaient pas nécessairement toujours
les plus liquides et donc se concentrer
excessivement là-dessus peut être
dangereux
deuxièmement en ce qui concerne les
hypothèses d'entrée sortie de deux des
bilans des différents types de dépôts de
ou de d'engagements de crédits les
hypothèses nous paraissent avoir des
marges de progression et ne pas être
complètement réaliste
donc j'espère que nous pourrons avancer
sur ces sujets assez rapidement parce
qu'il est clair que les banques
n'attendront pas 2015 pour leurs assauts
de court terme et 2018 pour leur assure
de long terme pour se mettre en
conformité que elles commenceront à
faire évoluer leurs bilans beaucoup plus
vite donc plus vite nous pourrons
clarifier les l'a compris le contenu
exact des ratios et mieux ce sera pour
nous manquons le système bancaire mais
pour ce qui est derrière surtout c'est à
dire le financement de l'économie
mondiale européenne et donc française
voilà monsieur le président merci
monsieur le gouverneur donc il nous
reste une demi-heure pour vous
interroger tu rapportes en général oui
monsieur le président je vais souhaiter
revenir sur quelques points très
brièvement sur le gouverneur je ne suis
pas satisfait je me permets de le dire
de la réponse que vous avez formulées à
une question précise sur l'application
de l'article 66 de la loi de régulation
bancaire et financière résidents arthuis
a rappelé une séance que ceux ci vise
l'augmentation des sommes déposées sur
les livrets a et livrets de
développement durable et l'augmentation
des sommes déposées et non centralisés
lorsque cette augmentation se produit
l'établissement de crédit collector va
consacrer au moins les trois quarts de
cette augmentation à l'attribution de
nouveaux prêts aux pme sous peine de
centralisation forcer le gouverneur si
la loi nous avons d'autant plus qu'elle
a pris naissance ici que c'est une
initiative que j'ai exprimée au nom de
cette commission des finances à l'égard
d'un gouvernement qui étaient réticents
mais au vu des chiffres qui étayaient
notre initiative qui la rendait
nécessaire
quelques mois après la loi est temps là
loin j'observe avec plaisir que le
président de la république à
saint-nazaire à saint nazaire s'est
félicité de ce dispositif
selon ses propres termes ceux-ci
aboutirait à mettre chaque année trois
milliards d'euros de plus à la
disposition des pme
la question que nous formulons est très
simple elle elle ne suppose pas de longs
développements techniques
c'est de disposer d'un tableau n'est ce
pas avec d'un côté le calcul de cette
augmentation
par groupes bancaires pas compliqué il
ya six grands groupes bancaires en
france et de l'autre l'affectation des
crédits aux pme en prenant bien entendu
une notion raisonnable de pme c'est pas
la peine d'attendre un arrêté
ministériel savoir que cette définition
existe dans le droit communautaire et il
est tout à fait loisible aux
établissements comme à la banque de
france d'appliquer cette définition
issue du droit communautaire donc je le
gouverneur sur ce sujet notre
questionnement est très simple nous
souhaitons que l'article 66 soit
appliquée et nous souhaitons disposer
d'outils de suivi qui en a sur
l'effectivité et je le répète c'est
simple c'est un tableau qui se décompose
en six groupes bancaires je me
permettrai de revenir sur un autre point
c'est à dire celui relatif à la
situation et des banques dans la zone
euro en d'autres termes au stress tests
et j'aurais souhaité monsieur le
gouverneur entendre de la part de
l'eurosystème que vous représentez dans
ce pays une autocritique
car si je ne m'abuse les tests de
résistance sont appliquées notamment à
l'irlande et il serait bon que l'on nous
dise pourquoi ils ont dysfonctionné et
quelles sont les mesures prises pour
éviter que de tels dysfonctionnements ne
se reproduise car il me semble que nous
sommes à nouveau passer à côté d'une
phase très difficile est liée à la
méconnaissance de la situation de cet
établissement irlandais et des
engagements pris pour le garantir
il serait utile que nous sachions si
toutes conséquences ont été tirées de ce
dysfonctionnement
enfin monsieur le gouverneur est
toujours dans le même esprit troisième
et dernière question
s'agissant de la mise en oeuvre des
plans de redressement et de
solvabilisation de la grèce et de
l'irlande
et quelles sont les modalités et de
reporting entre ces pays et la banque
centrale européenne et pouvez vous nous
dire comment se situe la banque centrale
européenne entre la commission et le
fonds monétaire international
et quel est le dispositif qui est mis en
oeuvre tant dans un sens que dans
l'autre sens et à votre connaissance
enfin la banque centrale européenne
missions telles régulièrement des
équipes pour s'assurer de la réalisation
des engagements pris par ces deux pays
et quel est le sort donner à ces
rapports d'audit s'il existe
merci de votre attention jim shaw vers
leur dîme ce résident général
s'agissant de l'application d'un tic 66
dès lors que vous me délivrer ce
problème je reconnais un peu
bureaucratique et de de piètres
importance
que j'ai signalé tout à l'heure je n'ai
aucun problème pour fournir à votre
commission le tableau que vous demandez
et donc nous allons le faire dans les
prochains jours pour que vous puissiez
vérifier que group un groupe
quels sont les chiffres ok ça serait
grand plaisir un respecter ainsi enfin
en tout cas apporter ma contribution à
la clarté sur le respect des tic 66,2
parce que bercy va rejoindre tout à
l'heure on avait l'impression que les
banques avaient prêté infiniment plus
que ce qu'elle avait collecté que dans
ces conditions il n'y avait pas hier le
gréement particulier or il s'agit ici
d'isoler ce qui a déjà été collectés
déjà prêté aux pme est de constater que
les flux les suppléments de collecte
sont effectivement un supplément de
prêts aux pme mais c'est des chiffres
seul président c'est simplement
littéraire des chiffres là je vous le
fournir ce tableau d'accord sur la base
de la définition des pme qui la
définition européenne française
réglementaire et qui est dans tous les
systèmes informatiques de la banque de
france des banquettes ce temps de
l'effet révérence
on se demande comment est elle arrêtée a
pu être conçue et préfecture est sérieux
mais c'est certainement je dire je
prends je prends sur moi le blâme de ne
pas voir un des plus vite au ministère
des finances qu'il était impératif de
revenir une définition simple connu pour
pouvoir appliquer des lois la loi ou une
façon générale sans d'hellemmes que je
veux qu'on peut encore faire des
économies dans les services de l'état il
me semble en effet que ce sera une
source de simplification et d'économies
sur la deuxième question monsieur
rapporteur général
alors effectivement
effectivement ces stress tests les deux
faiblesses
la première c'est que ils n'ont pas visé
alors sans doute parce qu'on a on a ont
été influencés par l'espace l'américain
qui n'avait visé que les grands
établissements mais on a il avait été
décidé c'était une décision de l'agencé
bancaire européenne et du conseil des
ministres d'ailleurs de ne demander que
au minimum deux banques par état il se
trouve que nous nous avons testé un peu
plus largement
l'espagne a décidé de tester beaucoup
plus largement parce qu'elle avait
décidé de toute façon de faire un stress
test national
mais dans beaucoup de pays il n'y a eu
que deux banques pour prendre le cas de
l'irlande
la banque qui a connu les plus grandes
difficultés qui est en train de
disparaître n'avait pas été testée
on veut pas dire que les stress tests
n'ont pas fonctionné les bancs la banque
n'avait pas été testée aussi simplement
bleus est riche puisque ces
établissements que je le pouvais mais
ont été désignés par chaque état donc
cette lacune n'est probablement pas un
hasard il faut dire les choses comme
elles sont je n'ai pas d'opinion là
dessus et nous mesurons la la la
perfectibilité de la gouvernance
européenne
et c'est comme la sincérité des comptes
grecs quoi
la seconde chose c'est que on a voulu
faire c'est reste reste est trop
rapidement
plus exactement il y a trois
sous-ensembles il y avait trois
sous-ensembles dans ces stress tests
le comité européen avait décidé dès le
printemps de faire un stress tests qui
n'a lieu à l'époque n'étaient pas
destinées de publier sur disons les 20
plus grandes banques européennes et donc
le travail avait été engagé a été fait
sur plusieurs mois de façon interactive
fouillés en vérifiant toutes les données
une façon très sérieuse
on a simplement ajouté à la fin un
module qui était pas très compliqué a
ajouté qu'ils étaient le module de la
crise souveraine mais et de l'effet d'un
effet assez complexe à la fois sur
portefeuille de négociation en mettant
tous à la valeur de marché et sur le
portefeuille bancaire en voyant les
répercussions sur le risque de crédit
attaché incendie portefeuille bancaire
des situations de tension souverain
était un peu complexe que la presse n'a
pas toujours complètement compris qui
était aussi dur que si on avait fait un
stress test général aux valeurs de
marché sur surtout mai mais pour c est
pour ces vins d'établissement le travail
a été fait 21 établissements le travail
a été fait sur une période assez longue
et très sérieuse selon bon bloc concerne
l'espagne l'espagne a fait c'était sur
une période plus courte mais un peu plus
longue que la pub qui étaient laissés
pour le reste des établissements parce
que l'espagne avait décidé de faire un
stress tests spécifiques surtout son
secteur bancaire
compte tenu de la pression qu'elle
sentait dans les marchés en porte et la
clarification au minimum de
planification et le troisième
troisième groupe ça a été les autres
états qui n'avait pas de grandes banques
justifier je clique était dans le
premier groupe et qui donc ont dû faire
cela dans une période très brève et sans
avoir forcément le temps de vérifier la
technologie de et mon sentiment
personnel est que alors je sais pas sur
le choix des établissements mais que le
fait de se restreindre à deux c'était la
difficulté à pouvoir faire dans une
période très bref un suivi du stress
fait sur sur un nombre assez élevé de
banques
quelles sont les conclusions en tirer
premièrement il faut des stress tests
qui soit qui s'applique de façon aussi
général que possible au système bancaire
pour prendre simplement la moitié ou le
tiers
deuxièmement il faut prendre le temps
nécessaire pour les faire sérieusement
et pouvoir se contrôler les uns les
autres et le tollé avoir le temps de
fouiller les différentes les différents
paramètres vérifier ce que cela donne et
c'est ce que on va essayer de faire dans
le dans le test qui est en préparation
actuellement sur les plans de redonner
moins d'élan plus précisé le gouverneur
dans ce test qui est donc en cours ou
prescrits qui va désigner les groupes
bancaires qui seront assujetties aux
contrôles qui je n'ai pas la réponse à
votre question je suppose que c'est ce
sera en tout cas
une décision formelle de l' agence
bancaire européenne
peut-être peut-être continuer à vivre
avec nous sans doute un avis du comité
européen de stabilité financière est
peut-être une décision définitive ou un
aval définitif donné par le conseil
ecofin
donc je vais vérifier cela je vous le
dirai plus précisément mais je pense
qu'il y aura pas effectivement ne
laissera plus des pays ne présentait que
les meilleurs établissements s'il y
avait le moindre en tout cas laisser le
soupçon qu'il aurait pu présenter
seulement le meilleur établissement je
suis instant de votre accord je trouve
qu'il faut non pas le droit à l'erreur
cette fois ci le mais je disais
maintenant tout cela pour vous dire que
par exemple je n'ai aucune inquiétude
sur le fait que les stresse thèse de ce
stress test lorsque nous l'avons fait en
france parce que nous avons pris le
nombre de mois nécessaire parce que nous
avions une grande habitude de faire des
stress tests n'ont publié les années
précédentes
nous pensons avoir la technologie nous
pensons que nos banques ont la
technologie
je suis très confiant sur le fait que ce
stress tests appliqués à la france il ya
un an
enfin oui à simon 8 mois a été de très
bonne qualité et je ne reviens pas
dessus mais voir la qualité comme l
inégale entre la france et l'irlande ou
d'autres pays enfin ça ne peut
qu'alimenter ce genre de constat ne peut
qu'alimenter la défiance la défiance des
marchés et les marges sur les conditions
d'emprunt et est vraiment ccc c'est une
à mon sens une considération de
confiance qui est absolument essentiel
je suis convaincue par
parce que vous dites monsieur le
reportage mais rech je ne pourrais pas
mieux dire sur la dernière question sur
les plans de redressement de la grèce et
l'irlande et les modalités d'association
de la bce les décisions qui ont été
prises par les états visent des missions
et les l'accord formel qui a été signé
par chacun des deux pays avec l'union
européenne vise une une surveillance de
l'exécution des programmes conjointe par
l'est et par le fmi et par la commission
européenne en liaison ce l'expression
utilisée en liaison avec la bce
très concrètement cela veut dire que les
équipes de la bce participent aux
missions d'inspection sur le terrain qui
sont faites par le fmi et par la
commission européenne régulièrement et
donc ont accès à tous les livres
tout est donné comme comme une mission
d'inspection veut avoir peut avoir accès
et donc la bce est en mesure de donner
son avis sur le respect ou le non
respect des différentes conditions qui
ont été mises dans les programmes d'être
signé donc des engagements et que
macroéconomiques ou structurelles qui
ont été pris par par les différents
états il fait il l'objet de procédures
formalisées
il y a par définition à chaud
régulièrement ce que le fmi appelle une
revue qui donne lieu à un rapport du fmi
qui va au conseil d'administration du
fmi sur l'adéquation de la politique
avec le programme la réalisation des
objectifs du programme et du côté de
l'union européenne
il ya un rapport de la commission qui va
fausser plus elle à l'éco finnois
l'eurogroupe groupe nes états de la zone
euro en tout cas question portait sur la
banque centrale européenne
est ce simplement un sous traitant du
fmi c'est un sous traitant de la
commission européenne si vous voulez non
c'est un associé à la commission
européenne salue un dieu c'est ça donne
lieu à venir un compte rendu par le
directoire de la bce au conseil des
gouverneurs oui merci
alors nous allons demander à celles et
ceux qui souhaitent l'interroger
s'exprimer maintenant et puis vous
répondrais globalement mêmes briques
d'abord
gouverneur que concernant le livret à la
centralisation c'est quand même les uns
et les autres
fortement exprimée donc ce n'est
peut-être pas la peine de dire venir en
revanche il ya une question à laquelle
nous n'avons jamais eu une réponse
claire et argumentée chiffres et c'est
l'engagement qui avait été pris lors du
de l'examen et du vote de la loi de
modernisation de l'économie en 2008 sur
la multi détention et le fait que les
l'outil statististiques n'était pas
opérationnel et que finalement on
demander une simple une simple
déclaration sur l'honneur qui très
souvent dans la pratique bancaire
n'était pas demandée au moment où il ya
eu quand même un rush dans les
établissements non historiques
concernant le livret a donc ça si vous
pouvez nous donner des éléments sur ce
point précis que nous avions demandé à
la ministre et qui s'était engagé à nous
les fournir assez rapidement ça fait
quand même bien tout ça fait à faire
bientôt trois ans que cette loi a été
votée
je voudrais revenir sur les stress tests
parce que chaque fois que vous êtes
devenu devant nous vous nous avez
finalement à peu près tenu le même
discours à savoir qu' il était fiable et
a même eu un communiqué extraordinaire
de madame lagarde le 23 juillet pour
dire que c'était avec grand succès que
les banques elles parlaient des banques
françaises vous y avait répandu mais moi
je vous interroge de la même manière que
je vous ai interrogé en 2008 alors je
vais commencer par quelque chose que je
sais que vous n'aimez pas aller à
l'époque vous aviez un peu fustigé les
méthodes du fmi trop inspiré des
pratiques anglo saxon et que les
méthodes européenne était bien meilleure
ce qui s'est passé en juillet dernier a
quand même montré que ce n'était pas
forcément meilleur mais il se trouve que
le fmi a lancé depuis le 19 janvier une
une série de stress tests sur l'europe
donc moi je voudrais qu'on réponde à une
caisse deux questions de principe
croyez-vous que tant qu'on ne connaîtra
pas et la réponse que vous avez fait à
la question du rapporteur général quand
on n'aura pas les éléments précis de la
méthodologie utilisée ça a été le
reproche qui a été fait à autostrade
tests de juillet qui ont été publiés en
juillet on ne connaît pas la
méthodologie qu'est-ce qu'on prend en
compte comment on le prend en compte et
qui le prend en compte
et puis le deuxième point quand même
c'est la transparence
on nous prend pour des andouilles faut
quand même le dire on est quand même
capable
nous parlementaires de responsabilité
par rapport à un tel sujet parce que on
va recommencer chacun va fournir sa
petite liste on ne connaîtra pas si on
prend en compte la solvabilité et la
liquidité et c'est bon et je termine par
une une question et puis si un problème
avec ce que fait le fmi qu'on compare
les méthodologies point par point et la
transparence qui est donné à ces à ces
stress tests et concernant les banques
françaises moi je voudrais aussi vous
interrogez c'est un peu lié mais pas
uniquement à l'exposition des banques
françaises aux
à certains des engagements qu'elles ont
dans certains pays j'ai fait le compte
quand on regarde le maghreb et l'egypte
je crois ça fait 50 milliards d'euros
l'exposition en irlande 52 milliards la
grèce 59 milliards ça fait à peu près
150 milliards d'exposition pour ces
zones géographiques
donc est-ce que je termine là est
monsieur le président est-ce que vous
pensez que c'est pas qu'est ce que ça
représente pour elle est ce qu'il y à un
risque pour elle est bon qu'ils peuvent
entraîner des tensions supplémentaires
est ce que il faudra leur fournir
peut-être à ce sujet une aide voilà
j'aimerais qu'on fasse le point parce
que j'ai vu ces chiffres dans la presse
heureusement quelques la presse existe
heureusement que la presse ait
effectivement monsieur le rapporteur
général
donc je pense que c'est quand même
important que nous on sache si ces
chiffres sont vrais est ce que ça
représente pour les établissements
français
ça c'est qu'on la suive moi j'ai vu dans
le journal sans citer le journal mais je
les ai eus dans le journal la semaine
dernière je crois voilà la parole est
maintenant à fabienne keller
oui merci beaucoup monsieur le président
monsieur le gouverneur de questions
concernant le livret a s'il me le permet
je souhaiterais compléter la question du
rapporteur général
s'agissant des crédits aux pme nouveau
crédit nous nous réjouissons tous de ce
ratio de deux fois et demie par rapport
aux obligations
mais nous ne sommes interpellés par la
contradiction éternel déjà longuement
discuté avec ce que nous disent les pme
sur sur le terrain et donc nous avons le
sentiment qu'il ya peut-être un sujet
autour du thermomètre
est-ce que vous pouvez compléter ses
tableaux par des commentaires sur la
méthodologie de chiffrage qui en son
temps avait été beaucoup moins favorable
puis a été adapté et puis aussi sur ce
que vous appelez précisément nouveaux
prêts
et avec quelles allaient à ceux ci peut
être mesurée par rapport à des
variations de stocks ou des ou des prêts
curan deuxième question sur le livret a
et sa centralisation g à côté d'eux - le
créateur de l'anru grand utilisateur des
fonds du logement social et dont les les
projections dans le temps et sur la
longue durée sont tout à fait
considérable comme celle du plan campus
ou des tgv qui sont également financés
je crois comme d'autres investissements
lourds par ces fonds centralisés les
ordres de grandeur sont considérables à
moitié au moins des plans de
transformation de nos quartiers
sensibles et du logement social en
général sont financés par ces mécanismes
cette centralisation est elle à la
hauteur du défi
cela nécessite un travail assez fin de
projection peut-être à cinq ou dix ans
mais on peut être inquiet de du risque d
car vous nous dites que les banques
financent le logement social on ne peut
que s'en réjouir
franchement nous les avons jamais
beaucoup croisé sur les plans de
financement ces matrices monstrueuse des
des programmes en rue si c'est le cas
nous nous en réjouissons et là aussi
seuls les chiffres permettront de le
prouver
mais au delà des banques qui à mon avis
sont complètement marginal dans le
dispositif
qu'en est il du lien entre la collecte
même si elles augmentent et ses besoins
de financements qui sont considérables
puisque en gros il concerne l'essentiel
les investissements de la france je vous
remercie
un reee hélène des esgaulx oui monsieur
le gouverneur vous avez déclaré je
croyais à bordeaux le mois dernier que
les banques centrales traite les crises
de liquidité et les états les crises de
solvabilité
moi je voudrais revenir sur cette phrase
qui m'interpelle un petit peu et je me
demande vraiment si les crises bancaires
que nous connaissons aujourd'hui en fait
elles mélangent pas justement tout c'est
de ces deux aspects je voudrais que vous
nous éclairer là dessus et deuxième
question j'ai lu par la presse que la
banque de france avait publié
en fait prévu une croissance pour 2011
pour le premier trimestre de 0 8%
bon ce qui est beaucoup ce qui serait
formidable d'ailleurs donc j'aimerais
que vous me donniez quelques éléments là
dessus mais moi je m'interroge quand
même
est ce que c'est vraiment nécessaire
d'être tout le temps dans cette
situation de prévision et on est dans
une danse dans une idée finalement que
systématiquement hong kong par l'insee
était à 0,3 vous vous avez annoncé 08
je trouve que tout ça crée une certaine
instabilité je me demande si vraiment
c'était nécessaire d'aller dans ce sens
mais peut-être que je me trompe
j'écouterai votre réponse avec beaucoup
d'attention merci françois marc
oui merci je peux y z'ont la question
sous gouverneur porte sur la politique
monétaire qui est pratiqué par les
banques centrales en général et au sein
de l'europe en particulier
on a vu la doctrine évoluer s'agissant
de l'achat des titres
on a entendu il y a quelques mois que il
était hors de question que les banques
centrales s'engageant c'est un tel
dispositif parce que il y avait quelque
chose à craindre en matière d'inflation
et on a vu progressivement ses doctrines
évolué aujourd'hui vous nous dites
eh bien on recherche un dispositif qui
permet de stériliser immédiatement
autant de liquidités sur le marché que
celles qui ont été générés par les
achats de titres réalisés par les
banques centrales
ma question est simple est-ce que vous
êtes sûr de cette étanchéité que vous
semblez à m a priori comme inhérente à
ce dispositif ce qui a pas au fond tout
de même un risque de déperdition est au
fond
il n'y at-il pas un risque que le taux
d'inflation de confort qui aujourd'hui
considéré à 2% par certaines banques
centrales et je pense en particulier à
la banque centrale américaine risque
d'évoluer peut-être vers deux ennemis
ouvert 3 % et non pas dans un processus
qui en mode pazzapa risque d'aboutir à
une inflation qui va progressivement
être admise par les institutions une
façon beaucoup plus importante qu'elle
est aujourd'hui
mais serge dassault beaucoup de
questions pour le gouverneur pas
répondre à tous vos questions peu
différentes sur la valeur de l'euro
aujourd'hui d'avoir de l'euro est très
préjudiciable à toute l'économie
européenne pour l'exportation zone
dollar sont très défavorisé est ce qu'on
peut vraiment pas envisagé un moment
donné une dévaluation bureau merci
pierre bernard et mro j'ai fait 9h45 de
train de nuit pour venir entendre le
gouverneur de la banque de france évoqué
le futur g20
je me sens un peu frustré c'était
pourtant le titre que j'avais noté sur
l'ordre du jour de cette réunion
est ce que vous pourriez nous en dire
deux mots
une dernière question si vous le
permettez on a bien compris qu'il
fallait renforcer les fonds propres des
banques on a bien compris que quand il s
risque systémique l'état et l assureur
systémique
vous avez en charge la surveillance des
banques
est ce que vous êtes en mesure de faire
la pression requis sur les gestionnaires
des banques pour que ils renforcent
leurs fonds propres par deux moyens
d'abord en régulant les niveaux de
rémunération des dirigeants et plus
globalement de leurs agents et ensuite
en régulant les niveaux de dividendes
versés aux actionnaires
est-ce que vous avez un vrai levier et
pour conforter ainsi les fonds propres
des banques
et puis enfin peut-être une toute
dernière question s'agissant de la grèce
et de l'irlande ont des vues qu' il y
avait une défaillance majeure en matière
de reporting et de sincérité des comptes
des états et cofondé et à trichet dans
la sincérité des comptes qu'il
présenterait au plan européen
est ce que les banques centrales est ce
que le réseau vous constituez ne serait
pas le l'échelon le plus pertinent pour
porter une appréciation sur la sincérité
des comptes publics
et est-ce que j'ai le sentiment
qu'aujourd'hui on a fait évoluer les
procédures et est-ce que vous évoquez
cela la banque centrale européenne est
ce que vous faites pression sur les
états pour que leurs comptes publics
soient plus conformes à la réalité
donc monsieur
j'ai essayé j'ai essayé monsieur le
président donc je commence par des
questions de madame briques sur sur sur
le livret a sur lequel la question de la
multi détention en réalité la seule
façon de faire on pourrait monter un
système alternatif il se trouve que le
le système informatique qui était monté
historiquement pour suivre les
différents comptes est un outil fiscal
que vous connaissez c'est un fichier
fiscal pour des raisons que
personnellement j'ai jamais compris
c'est que je les dis à l'époque où
j'étais au ministère des finances il ya
quelques années de cela je n'ai jamais
compris pourquoi on n'avait pas mis les
livrets réglementés
dès le départ dans ce fichier mais il ya
une espèce de réticences de
l'administration à toucher à cela il est
clair que c'est ce qui est en cours et
c'est la seule façon de vérifier la
multi détention c'est d'utiliser cet
outil
si l'état décide de transférer ce
fichier à bandes de france moi je veux
bien le gérer mais puisque c'est un
outil qui est une une un objectif
fiscale
c'est très bien qu'il a qui restent là
bas il faut simplement que tous les
comptes soient rentrés sur ce fichier et
la multi détention
se verra immédiatement il peut y avoir
des missions de l'inspection des
finances en en complément mais
normalement ça se verra automatiquement
dans cet outil fiscal le fichier dit
ficoba
c'est en cours je ne sais pas exactement
où ils en sont oui c'est sans doute un
peu long tu es sans doute un peu long
mais je ne sais pas je ne sais pas c'est
une question qu'il faut poser au
ministre des finances madame
malheureusement mais si vous me donnez
la charge dans une question écrite sur
les sur les stress tests la méthodologie
que nous avons utilisée a été publié à
l'été et publié de la même façon elle a
été publiée de la même façon que la
méthodologie des stress tests américains
on a vraiment copié sur fois copié ou la
faune a fait quelque chose de largement
aussi transparente les stress tests
américains et nous avons également fait
communiqué publié ce qu'il y avait comme
expo silos des expositions souveraines
par par l'ensemble des banques les ont
pas beaucoup plus mais ça a été fait la
difficulté avec les stress tests mais
pas celle là le problème c'est qu'un
stress tests ça n'est ni ni la la
photographie de la réalité puisqu'on
imagine une situation de stress extrême
ni une prévision on se place dans une
hypothèse qui est une hypothèse
artificielle ou qu'on cherche à être
aussi défavorable que possible en
combinant des hypothèses de stress alors
qui parfois se trouvait dans certains
domaines en dessous de la réalité un
jour parfois son
où souvent sont très au delà de la
réalité on n'a pas connu en était une
situation de stress au niveau de la zone
euro dans son ensemble qui approche est
de loin ce que nous avions fait à
l'époque et c'est la raison pour
laquelle tu fais quelque chose sur des
hypothèses qu'on essaye de faire des
hypothèses dur par exemple hypothèses
macroéconomiques était celle d'une
replongée dans la récession n'a pas
replongé dans la récession
il se trouve que pour les états qui ont
été sous pression il ya eu une replongée
dans la récession donc hypothèses
macroéconomiques faite par la bce à
l'époque c'est elle qui a été
responsable
elle a été juste pour l'irlande ou la
grèce là était fausse pour la france ou
l'allemagne
mais c'est cela qui rend qui rend les
choses difficiles mais franchement moi
je peux vous re re communiqué la
commission si vous le souhaitez la
méthodologie qui avaient été publiées
sur les stress tests vous verrez que
c'est c'est assez complet donc c'est pas
du tout l'idée de ne pas être
transparents ou de cacher des choses
simplement ce triste et c'est compliqué
ça qu historiquement on en faisait un
outil de supervision et bien entendu la
qualité du stress tests et là vous les
questions vous me posez sont tout à fait
juste il vous me permettez de le dire
tiens beaucoup à la qualité avec
laquelle sont faits par les mangas ils
sont contrôlés par les superviseurs
donc quand on est un superviseur qui a
plusieurs années d'expérience dans les
stress tests on s'est aperçu des erreurs
qu'on a faites il ya quelques années on
a pu améliorer notre méthode de
vérification de surveillance d'exigence
pour ceux qui débutent y ait forcément
une période d'appréhension et je trouve
que le ce que vous avez mis en avant
c'est à dire la nécessité de se
contrôler les uns des autres de
s'échanger nos techniques les uns les
autres mais c'est la voie dans laquelle
il faut aller on doit tous progressé
tout à fait clair dans la banda le
sérieux enfin bouhlal la solidité des
exercices que nous faisons ces questions
de
même qu'elle est sûre le les nouveaux
crédits aux pme
je sais bien qu'il ya toujours un
sentiment des pme tout simplement parce
que les banques ne dise pas oui aux
demandes de crédit des pme dans toutes
les circonstances et qu'elles peuvent
avoir tel ou tel avoir un sentiment qui
n'est pas qui n'est pas conforme à ce
que disent les statistiques
moi je ne note plusieurs choses
premièrement sur les fêtes
nous avons eu 4 4% de croissance des
crédits aux pme contre 1,6 pour cent des
crédits aux entreprises en général
l'année dernière donc ça veut bien dire
que le crédit aux pme a été n'a pas été
contraint ce taux est le plus important
de la zone euro pas dire qu'il est
parfait et le plus important de la zone
euro les taux d'intérêt des crédits aux
pme en france sont les plus faibles de
la zone euro
ils sont 40 à 50 points de base
inférieur à ce qu'ils sont en allemagne
par exemple est et dans les dernières
enquêtes que nous qui ont été faites au
niveau de la de l'ensemble de la zone
euro tant du côté des banques que du
côté des entreprises le retour que nous
avons et que les conditions sont jugés
d'une façon générale satisfaisant alors
c'est une vérité statistique ce pas dire
que ce soit le cas individuellement pour
chaque pme auprès de chaque guichet
bancaire
sachant que la pme elle même peut être
de t'avoir peut avoir raison elle peut
avoir un billet dans le jugement de sa
propre situation et qu'évidemment des
entreprises qui sont qui sont en
difficulté de lieu à une
une réticence compréhensible des banques
mais ce n'est évidemment pas cela que
vous visiez sur le logement social
ce que j'ai dit n'est pas une opinion
sur les montants qui seraient
nécessaires
ce que je dis simplement c'est que le
mieux est l'ennemi du bien et que si les
chiffres démontraient que vous avez
besoin pour satisfaire les besoins de
financement de centraliser presque la
totalité des montants du livret a
et pour avoir un coût de financement
acceptable sans subvention budgétaire de
baisser le taux de commissionnement près
de zéro le résultat est certain vous
n'aurez rien donc c'est tout ce que je
dis ensuite c'est un problème
d'arbitrage c'est exactement comme en
matière fiscale que des tas de choix qui
sont possibles on sait que certains
choix conduisent à faire se rétracter la
matière fiscale et à faire disparaître
donc une partie de l'impôt qu'on veut
appréhender c'est c'est un choix je ne
me prétends pas me mettre à la place du
législateur pour du gouvernement pour
faire ce choix je dis simplement d'un
équilibre qui est fragile et auquel il
faut faire attention et la maximisation
des montants qu'on peut lever ne passe
pas forcément par le taux de
centralisation le plus le plus élevé par
ailleurs dans les choix qui ont été
faits par l'état que je ne conteste pas
il ya par exemple le choix d'ouvrir à la
banque postale la capacité de faire des
prêts
aux entreprises ce qui va justifier une
baisse du taux de centralisation est
clair que si un autre choix avait été
fait ici la banque postale vais
continuer à centraliser 100% ce pour
l'instant elle fait il est plus facile
d'atteindre des taux de centralisation
élevé compte tenu de sa part de marché
encore une fois je ne conteste pas du
tout ce choix mais il est à prendre en
compte aussi d'en enlever dans les
prévisions
je crois que la question qui m'a été
pesé après madame oui c'était sur les
deux crises de liquidité crise de
solvabilité
c'est vrai c'est vrai que les crises de
liquidité crise de solvabilité on passe
très facilement de l'une dans l'autre
donc la présentation était sans doute un
peu académique et est pas complètement
fin de n'intégrer pas ses liens qui peut
y avoir entre liquidités solvabilité je
dire que ce que je voulais souligner
c'est qu'une banque centrale quand elle
fait par exemple une assistance de
liquidités d'urgence elle fait parce
qu'il ya eu un problème de
d'alimentation en liquidités de la
banque mais quelle fondamentalement
saine que ces crédits ne sont pas des
crédits compromis et que ses fonds
propres sont suffisants
donc à ce moment-là on apporte une
liquidité en l'aider à passer un cap et
attend dans la restauration de la
confiance du marché
si on s'aperçoit que c'est une banque
est en réalité en faillite ou qu'il
devrait l'être à ce moment là c'est pas
nous qui allons la recapitaliser la
nationaliser la la nettoyer c'est à
l'état que ça revient est évident que
quand on a comme banque centrale ce qui
est fréquemment le cas aujourd'hui une
responsabilité en tant que superviseur
on a
on a une action des deux côtés et je ne
peux pas me dire que ce que vous avez
dit sur la croissance de 0,8 en quelques
mots l'insee a fait une prévision mi
décembre
depuis lors l'insee elle même a publié
un chiffres pour décembre un chiffre
pour janvier notamment de production
manufacturière qui étaient deux très
bons mois de très bons chiffres et nous
avons intégré les dernières données de
denquête alors quand on essaye de
décomposer ceux qui apparaissent et qui
a notamment un effet assez fort de la
fin de la prime à la casse sur les
commandes de véhicules et donc les mises
en production décembre et en janvier
et donc c'est un effet qui ne qui n'est
pas représentatif nécessairement de ce
que seront les trimestres suivants
vous pouvez un très fort premier
trimestre pas dire qu'on va avoir quatre
trimestres aussi forts
évidemment le fait d'avoir un j'espère
un quatrième trimestre assez fort nous
avions dit devant des prévisions qui
sont proches de celles de l'insee
d'ailleurs de 0,5 0,6 et si si si note
si nous avons vu juste bien sûr c'est
notre enquête et confirmé y avoir un
premier trimestre très fort aidera à
avoir une moyenne un peu meilleur sans
doute que les prévisions qui ont été
faites par par les instituts mais ça
change pas forcément fondamentalement le
la direction générale de la croissance
qui est une accélération mais lente de
la croissance retour vers le potentiel
d'avant la crise en ce qui concerne d'un
jeu marque la politique mais faire des
banques centrales et les achats de
titres est en réalité deux philosophies
vous avez très bien noté est une
philosophie qui est celle pratiquée par
par la fed aux états unis et par la
banque d'angleterre qui est une
politique qui s'appelle quantitative
easing 2 2 lille justement quantitatif
où il l'objectif est de lutter contre un
risque de alors en angleterre à cette
l'objectif de lutter contre un risque de
rétraction de rétraction de la masse
monétaire en un an forçant l'injection
de liquidités dans l'économie
c'était au fond le la crainte d'une
d'une déflation qui justifiait cela est
volontairement et crée la liquidité aux
états unis c'est plus clairement en tout
cas dans la phase actuelle volonté de
peser sur la courbe des taux sur les
taux longs donc là aussi font injecter
de la liquidité
il injecte de la liquidité sans la
reprendre dans notre cas c'est très
différent
nous avons toujours refusé en effet
comme vous l'avez noté cette idée d'
injecter de la liquidité à travers des
achats de titres publics
nous considérons que c'est pas ça n'a
jamais été le problème même au plus fort
de la crise nous référions le faire en
injectant de la liquidité dans le
système bancaire pour pour générer
l'actif poissy et de générer de
l'activité de crédit facilité l'activité
de crédit sens en refusant de se
concentrer sur le titre public
nous nous l'avons fait uniquement pour
cette raison de mauvaise transmission de
la politique monétaire au fond les faits
l'effet induit
deux des problèmes des états sur les
banques et donc sur le coût du crédit et
le fait que donc nos taux d'intérêt
n'était plus du tout reflétée dans le
coût du crédit ont certaines zones de
réseaux neuraux mais comme nous le
faisions donc dans cette optique très
particulière nous avons considéré qu'il
fallait très nettement se démarquer de
la politique de quantitative easing et
ne pas du tout aller dans cette
direction mais est ce que le fonds
européen de stabilité financière ne va
pas constituer le réceptacle et ce
serait bien s'il prenait le relais wi et
au fond est ce qu'on a fait ce qu'on a
pas la construction qui va permettre de
dire que la banque centrale était
absolument orthodoxe irréprochable mais
qu'au fond on a créé juste à côté une
sorte de consortium je dis pas de
réalisation mais où l'on récupère des
des petits papiers de qualité diverse
quoi nous nous faisons l'hypothèse que
c'est ces papiers rond échéance et
seront et seront remboursées mais mais
ce qui est très clair ce que nous
n'aimons pas intervenir comme cela
massivement sur les aides publiques
c'est pas notre rôle est surtout si nous
étions aujourd'hui ce que nous serons
demain j'espère dans une dans une
situation
on alimente plus aussi facilement les
banques en liquidités
il faut que nous soyons sûrs de ne
pouvoir donner que la liquidité
exactement nécessaires dans le système
la technique que nous avons monté qui
consiste à faire des reprises de
liquidités auprès des banques nous
permet d'être sûr que nous avons bien
les montants pris le jour nous
reviendrons à des des adjudications
traditionnel de liquidités auprès du
système bancaire nous sont revenus dans
le mode transition d'alimentation il
suffira simplement d'ajuster la
liquidité montant liquidités qu'on donne
en réduisant de tout le portefeuille des
faits publics nous aurons encore à ce
moment là et nous pourrons le faire
encore plus simplement
donc j'ai pas d'inquiétude techniquement
il est clair que en communication c'est
pas simple puisque l'on compte seulement
deux centrales n'ont utilisé cette
technique avec des objectifs
complètement différent
le gouverneur je voulais répondre m
d'ambert extrêmement synthétique et pour
les questions plus techniques peut-être
de nous faire parvenir une note que nous
joindrons aux comptes rendus d'auditions
très bien donc sur la valeur de l'euro
avant chose à dire monsieur dassault
connaît connais ma réponse mais je dirai
simplement je considère qu'il ya il ya
deux types de problèmes y en a un qui
est des relations entre les grandes
monnaies problème classique du g7
nous sommes dans le système de
flottement où c'est le marché qui fixe
les taux et en même temps il y avait une
surveillance du g7 pour éviter qu'on
peinte vers des configurations de change
est normal aujourd'hui et c'est un des
problèmes du g20 fait la transition avec
la question sur le g20 nous sommes dans
une configuration où la montée de
plusieurs économies émergentes fait que
le g7 ne représente plus et seule grande
économie mondiale
or les pays émergents ont des politiques
de change très différentes les unes des
autres
certaines très fixe comme comme la chine
d'autres en principe adopter le même
système de flottement mais inquiète de
l'appréciation très rapide dans certains
pays comme comme le brésil ou la corée
ont pu avoir des politiques de
d'intervention août contrôle des changes
aussi de freiner les choses
donc nous sommes dans une situation qui
est un peu instable et c'est bien ce qui
est derrière l'idée je crois du présent
dans les publics de vouloir poser
question du système monétaire
international est ce que nous pouvons
rebâtir ensemble un système qui soit
plus équilibrée plus solide et qui
répondent mieux aux besoins de toutes
les économies donc à la maximisation du
bien-être mondiale enfin sur votre
question sur les fonds propres
monsieur le président sur le reste du
g20 avec votre permission je
transmettrai une petite note à la
commission pour vous décrire la façon
dont nous voyons l'ensemble des choses
sur les fonds propres
oui je considère que nous sommes dans
mesure de faire pression sur les banques
nous nous nous discutons avec elle en
début d'année
nous discutons avec elle la trajectoire
d'augmentation de leurs fonds propres et
nous leurs disons vous devez respecter
cette trajectoire et par conséquent
votre politique de rémunération est
votre politique de dividende doit
s'ajuster à cela et nous nous opposerons
un add par exemple la politique de
distribution de dividendes qu'ils ne
permettraient pas de respecter la
trajectoire donc à vous de le respecter
spontanément sur les rémunérations n'a
un règlement de décembre plus en
application de serre des trois que nous
allons faire respecter très étroitement
bien entendu enfin sur la question de la
sincérité des comptes
l'idée sur laquelle nous entrerions nous
nous sentons interpellés comme banque
centrale céderait de ne pas avoir vu
certaines certaines déviations c'était
surtout le cas en grèce je dois dire des
c'est là que le le 15 mai mais on
n'avait pas d'explicitations la solution
qui a été choisie qui me paraît bonne et
à laquelle les banques centrales
prêteront évidemment leur conte qu
autant que nécessaire c'est de donner à
eurostat des pouvoirs intrusif vers la
possibilité d'aller enquêter sur place
d'aller vérifier d'aller fouiller dans
les comptes
c'est indispensable et est naturellement
la bce l'eurosystème seront prêts à
apporter leur concours parce que nous
avons besoin comme tout le monde comme
les parlements d'y voir clair
dans les comptes publics merci monsieur
le président merci monsieur le
gouverneur cette sincérité est une des
conditions de la confiance dont vous
compléterez peut-être par quelques notes
on les demandes auxquelles vous n'avez
pas répondu notamment l'exposition des
banques françaises aux engagements
s'ouvre pour compléter l'information
nous avons au travers de la presse sinon
vous pouvez nous éclairer à ce sujet
nous vous en remercieront merci
infiniment
nous allons suspendre 30 secondes
jusqu'à nos invités économistes nous ont
déjà rejoints et qu'il s'impatiente
c'est la fin de cette audition si vous
souhaitez la revoir notre site internet
publicsenat.fr
prochain rendez vous avec elle et
travaux parlementaires cet après midi
16h30 vous pourrez suivre la suite de
l'examen du projet de loi consacré à
l'immigration très bonne journée à tous
sur public sénat